this program is brought to you by Emory
University
it started out for me I went to the room
ologist because my joints were swelling
my ankles would swell and whatnot so I
went for that and he told me you know
rheumatoid arthritis I said fine and
then one day I was sitting at work and I
realized that my eyes were bothering me
but I had not paid much attention and I
worked in the medical field I was a
phlebotomist I went into my
dermatologist office and I was standing
against the wall waiting for her past
five minutes a good morning ma'am and
she's good morning money and she stopped
and looked at my eyes look deep into my
what's that I did and I waited and she
says you've got lupus I thought I said
dr. Sharpe is lost her mind so she walks
on by two days later I'm sitting in my
office all alone and on the wall in
front of me is a club that you hang
outside your door when you're preparing
to leave and go to lunch and you say I
will be back as such and such a time I
couldn't read it I read that clock every
day for seven years I could not read the
clock so I jumped on the phone and right
across the street was my ophthalmologist
and I can't iritis and it's a chronic
thing when my lupus flares that's what
happens to me most I lost twenty-five
percent of my vision at that time trying
to figure out what was going on and he
said the same thing I think you have
lupus but we're going to call it mixed
connective tissue disease until
something different happens so my major
things are my eyes my joints
fibromyalgia and I just found out last
week that my cardiologist feels that my
chronic chest pain is because of the
lupus affecting the wall my chest wall
so those are my things my initial
diagnosis was not lupus it was mixed
connective tissue
these because of back ten years ago we
always have to do an le prep and the le
prep would be positive but every other
test would be borderline or negative so
no one except for ER doctors would save
me disables just in the bus but no one
would give me a diagnosis of lupus
without those positive tests and so my
first initial diagnosis only came about
three years ago what the diagnosis
itself I will say that it did not the
diagnosis didn't change me but since the
diagnosis since that swept that initial
swelling and made me look like an
elephant from the hips down my flares
help increased so it was like the
beginning of a real reality check I
thought that if I had lupus that it was
only going to affect my vision and maybe
I break out with wretch every now and
then that's what I thought but it's been
a little bit different than that I'm
Hannah more more players and they didn't
come as frequent and I like the
chopped-up is getting wiser getting
rationale the skin rash that I do get it
comes and goes but as a child it came
often and as soon as my mom would said
she called make that appointment and by
the time I got there the rest would be
gone so we could not go by the rash and
my dermatologist she would um when the
rash would come up she would punch out
part of the ranch and try and see what
it is and they came up with this crazy
name that probably has about 17 letters
in it I couldn't say it if I tried it
begins with the cat but she says form of
eczema and it probably comes from you
having lupus she kept repeating that you
have look to see
but she has some as I said ER doctors
were the only ones they would actually
say it until I three years ago I went to
the doctor and I told look at my legs
look at my feet and she stood school yes
they are really swollen for you I said
this is not normal this is not a normal
swelling like from my heart congestive
heart failure it's not normal so she
says you want me to run some tests and I
said yes and she called me and she says
I'm sorry with all this other stuff you
guys you are now officially a lupus
patient i said well whatever i can't say
that over the years doctors treated me
well they didn't treat me as though I
was crazy or heaven you know imagining
my symptoms I had been on the lupus
drugs off and on over those 10 years so
they always treated me as aggressively
as I thought that they could without me
having an actual diagnosis of Lucas as I
said dr. Elm is great he supports my
thoughts about my own health he makes
sure that I have everything that I need
I think I need a want to hang out he'll
try anything for a little while let's
see whether or not it works it I really
love dr. Lu
you
the preceding program is
by Emory University